it's been a grueling few weeks um but i
want to say a few thank yous
i want to say a massive thank you to
jackie gedman the returning officer
and her team um for for organizing this
evening
and all the staff that have been
involved in doing the count tonight
i want to say a huge thank you to the
police who sadly i have needed more than
ever
over the last few weeks and i want to
say a huge
thank you to the whole liber party team
for the hours
and the time and their commitment
they've put in to supporting me
and helping me to get to this fantastic
result this evening
well done for keeping up everybody um
there's way too many people to mention
by name
but i do want to refer to my family and
my friends
who without them i could have not got
through the last five years
never mind the last five weeks my
amazing parents
and my wonderful partner and i want to
give a special shout out to my niece and
nephew
who i cannot wait to hug as soon as i
see them
the focus now is catching up on a bit of
sleep um
maybe having a few glasses of fizz um
and then there's lots to do
and i think the campaign has highlighted
that there's lots to do
but i'm going to crack on with it and i
will do my very best
to represent the whole of batley and
spen as their new mp
i'm absolutely delighted that the people
of batley and spen have rejected
division and they've voted for hope
thank you very much everybody
so there we have it what an incredible
result
certainly something that the bookies
didn't expect the pundits didn't expect
the pollsters
didn't expect a labor win in the battley
and spain
by-election kim ledbeter getting 13
hundred and ninety six votes uh
incredibly close ryan stevenson for the
conservatives
as you uh can see twelve thousand nine
hundred
and seventy three so she won the
by-election
by by my counting by just 323
votes we knew all through the last few
hours that it was going to be close but
perhaps no one expected it to be
quite that close and an emotional
kim led beta there talking about a
gruelling
few weeks making a point to thank the
police saying that she's needed the
police
more than ever and of course she also
thanked her supporters her family
her friends we know that the the labor
support she's received on the ground has
been
huge and she said she thanked all of
them not only for the last part
five weeks but for the last five years
very emotionally she said that she had
lots to do
the campaign has highlighted exactly
that she was
absolutely delighted john craig is
at that count for us well john what do
you make of that
well what i make of it is that the past
seven or eight weeks have seen
british politics turned upside down with
three
shock results three sensational results
first of all we have the tories winning
a spectacular victory
in hartley pool uh in the so-called
labour red wall
then that was on the 6th of may turmoil
in the labour party followed that
then a few weeks ago on the 17th of july
we see the talk we saw the tories lose
to the liberal democrats
in cheshire and amisham uh a shock
result that nobody really forecast
and tonight as you've said uh jonathan
with
all the bookies the pundits the
um the uh the the opinion pollsters
all pointing to a comfortable
conservative win
uh the most recent poll i can think of
had the conservatives at 47 percent
i think it was labour at 41 and
at one stage the bookies had labor in
third place i think that was ladbrokes
from memory
and now we've had labour uh winning a
by-election so
each of the three main political parties
has pulled off a shock result
the last few weeks this one my word
uh this one has uh really possibly been
the biggest shock of all
although uh although uh cheshire and
amazon was a big surprise as well
and it has been an extraordinary
by-election i won't say it's been a
by-election like no
other but it has been one of the most
ill-tempered
and divisive and acrimonious
by-elections
of recent years there are always
accusations of dirty tricks in
by-elections
but this one of course there has been
accusations of assaults
police have got involved homophobic uh
slurs
there have been racist accusations
accusations of racism as well
um fake leaflets all sorts of dirty
tricks assaults on canvassers and
supporters
and there as you mentioned jonathan
normally
it's just uh it's just polite uh to
thank the police
but she said sadly i've needed them more
than ever
this past five weeks uh it was a speech
as you say from emotion
but humility also it wasn't the sort of
speech that you often hear a by-election
winner give
which no doubt has been written by some
party hack in
party hq it was a very personal speech
and she talked about how the voters here
had rejected
division what a sensational result
what a comeback by labour when they were
written off
sir kier starmer's political obituary
was being written by some of his critics
the labour left were getting ready to
mount a challenge or threaten
a challenge calls for him to step down
diana but said it'd be curtains
uh if he if labour lost here and
uh len mccluskey said that zakir would
be consigned to the dustbin of history